los republicanos estadounidenses Se
salieron con la suya el tribunal supremo
alargó la vida del título 42 una norma
de pandemia de Donald Trump que permitía
al gobierno expulsar rápidamente a
migrantes hacia México
está expiraba el miércoles 21 de
diciembre pero una moción de 19 estados
republicanos fue bien vista por el
máximo tribunal Texas y otros Estados
insisten en que la corte deje el título
42 en su lugar la orden de hoy es un
paso en esa dirección esto ayuda a
prevenir la migración ilegal el fallo es
temporal y la administración biden puede
presentar nuevos argumentos el martes
pase lo que pase ciudades fronterizas
como el paso han estado preparándose
una de las cosas que vamos a hacer es
seguir procediendo como si se estuviera
levantando queremos asegurarnos de que
estamos preparados
entre 9000 y 14.000 personas han estado
llegando de forma diaria motivadas por
la expiración de un título que
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
consideraban limitaba que la gran
mayoría de personas pudieran solicitar
asilo Todos queremos pasar porque todos
tenemos un sueño
de cruzar trabajar y sacar adelante
nuestra familia y darle a nuestros
padres que quedaron allá después de
cerca de tres años en vigor 2,5 millones
de personas se han visto afectadas por
el título 42 y pese a todo miles de
migrantes continúan llegando a una
frontera saturada y en plena o la
invernal